do super white Sal it's the super white
is like I still do the white dances no
it's got court we're live by the way I
think so we may be live I don't know
come on FAL we are life we are like hey
everybody welcome back to the weekly
pool I'm getting an ad on Twitch Hey
look they're promoting daredevil I'm
Betty the comic story and you guys know
me this is my twitch channel which is
oddly dubbed the eligible monster
channel go figure that is self from
comic pop TV little house and whatever
else Sal wants to change his name to
next week that is fast from it's super
effective in a thousand top-secret
projects that involve Marvel and that is
Sammy of Sammy reads one of the many
contributors to the weekly pull net if
you want to be a part of the weekly
pulled on net go check out the website
and contact Sal because I do not
regularly hello Sammy no one's ever met
you boo and we lost damn he's picked ya
edits back and I just started a channel
quite literally two months ago talking
about comma key things so here ya know
she's been doing a great job over the
channel if you go to the weekly pulled
on that on the very bottom you will see
contributors which right now is only
Sammy but very soon it will actually
have Jason back in and and comic island
it's just Sammy's playlist the only one
that seems to work right now so alright
guys so today's topics are going to be
obviously convergence of last week Faust
loved it Sal hated Betty just didn't
read it so we'll find out what's gonna I
did I did a whole video and then we're
gonna talk about Joker's amazing makeup
and wide the tattoos are the greatest
thing in the world and then we're gonna
talk about Bobby Drake being announced
as gay and what if Al's feelings on this
are cuz he was ranting the long before
the podcast we had to stop him he was
like nope nope podcast rant podcast
so why don't we kick this off with
convergence and we'll start we'll start
in the what I've got on the screen here
Sal you're on the upper left-hand corner
so why don't you kick off our converge
discussions well we're up in what are we
on issue for now or at least it's coming
up tissue for and the merry old you know
Wizard of Oz gang is skipping across the
desert and fighting Telos I guess cares
actually if you purchase cuz no one you
like is in that hold I thought real
quick so because I'm gonna answer one
question that everyone's gonna ask you
till we say it Rob actually just stepped
out today guys I know it's normally me
that gets too busy to the podcast today
Rob needed to so we decided to take this
opportunity to move things over to
twitch as we've been promoting for quite
some time and test out a couple of
things that's why it's located here
right now
Rob we'll be back next week it's just
he's busy today that's all yeah yeah
it's not he wasn't caught an incursion
barrel thing yeah or his what his
reality wasn't converged he's fine he's
not dead pole smashing between two
worlds yeah you know what I'm actually
not really that down on convergence
although I am rereading identity crisis
and I'm like oh I remember what DC used
to try and make everything work and this
is kind of it's I don't know what do you
what do you guys think I think it's I
think it's fine like it's coming along
this last issue I think issue three was
kind of a dud like it was it felt like
you could really just read the wiki and
then move on like just just wait some
before okay so my feelings on the main
title is that and I've been saying this
in all of my compares reviews they've
got a story but the story is not enough
to fit into eight issues so they spread
it very very thin across the lake issues
and really they could have just done it
in like full I mean about those first
couple issues they felt very like
exposition II and I was like I don't
believe like that the the second issue I
think was the worst where they did the
first issue where they literally just
said here's earth to look at them have
fun and it's almost as if when they got
to the second issue summit at DC was
like did anybody mention where these
guys came from should we do like an
Origin opening so we can explain this a
little better right I was taught
Tiffiny one of the members of comic pop
yesterday and I was like oh man can't
wait to wrap up with conversions number
four she's like it's eight I'm like
there's five more books and I'm like oh
because we're doing weekly like every
episode of off-the-rack is dedicated to
the main title and one of the tie-ins
and oh my god like thankfully the tight
ends are co-star the show obviously like
the the tie-ins are the ones that are
like what people buy
if anyone's buying I know if we did you
guys read that article about how like
it's one store that I record about but
I've heard stories since then that like
convergence is killing comic book stores
right now normally everyone who comes in
a normally buy his DC it's kind of like
Tim Owen Batman 40 comes out so long
take it out of my pull list I want to
write any of it No oh yeah no it's
really hurting yeah work directly where
they come it looks to retailer I mean
how's it going over there
yeah no he laughs about it every week
that I come in and I'm like I need every
issue of convergence he's like can you
take all the other ones off of my shelf
please yeah I definitely get that from
like the comics retailer side of things
because I mean I worked in a comic book
store for three years so when the title
was I mean when it was announced I was
just kind of like oh okay
and I mean it's so hard to predict what
people are gonna like like are they just
gonna want that main storyline are they
gonna like all the tie ins is it gonna
be good so it's just really difficult
and it is especially difficult because
this one's an event where you don't need
to read the tie-ins at all which is good
it's been what we've saying we want but
it's like the tie-ins on exactly
relevant in many things yeah and it's
funny because like if they had played I
wonder I wonder this I wonder if the
tie-ins had been a few moments before
Brainiac had taken the cities if it was
not life in the dome and it was instead
just like the realities the last time we
saw them and then it ended like each
issue ended with like oh no or city has
been taken or some crap like if it had
been not connected with with with
convergence like at all if they'd be
more
they'd be more enjoyable I feel like
maybe I mean but the the pretending like
well I've been in like Catwoman is a
horrible issue but it really sold the
premise of like Gotham under the dome or
metropolis under the dome and I'm like
that's cool like if you had an
autonomous city that had no connection
to the outside world like the food would
be controlled by whoever was in charge
and if you have inter-gang then your
will be controlled by energy like my
whole thing is why is everyone either in
Gotham or metropolis Naoko City no
central city like what the hell maybe at
least for like just publicity at least
well the biggest issue I have with the
convertors tie-ins in general is kind of
what you were saying but I think that
would Dan my editor because we've been
doing the weekly the weekly whole
convergence overview and I have noticed
is that there's like three different
times and it's almost like nobody sat
down and said we need to have a decisive
plan for this you have the tie-in that
jokes about the whole thing which is
what I did like about the Supergirl
matrix one they just made fun of the
whole thing you don't care about her you
don't care about this no one asks for
this comic here we are they like the
idea yeah then you have the ones that
are completely serious on the whole
thing like the dome came down and this
is how I've been coping with the entire
event like that's what Barry Allen did
like the whole issue was Barry Allen
being like I accept that this is my life
now there's no superhero we can't do
this this isn't gonna work
and then the dome comes up like my
speaking of Barry Allen like my issue
with the flash sort of tie-in was that
as the flash you expect something fast
you expect something fun it was so slow
that was to represent Barry doesn't have
any powers so it's slow now but it
wasn't like a good slow it was just uh
can I just read the flash I know he's
gonna get his powers back of red
everything else there's also the third
one the third one where they practically
ignore the convergence itself event and
they pretty much within the first page
or two they just open it up as domes
gone here we go we're gonna fight yeah I
mean like I've heard a lot of positive
criticism about the Superman one where
they I think it was one page of Superman
having no powers and it was like domes
down Superman's got powers moving on
that was the first time we read now it's
like this if this is how it's gonna go
this can be pretty cool nope see what I
liked about the New Teen Titans issue
was like the dome was gone about halfway
into the comic but it still wasn't about
fights it was about drama in the team
house is selected each other you know
like that's what the New Teen Titans did
back in the day and Marvel comments on
it and was obviously on the original run
of the new ten times so you would kind
of expect that anyway and if that wasn't
there people would have complained but I
don't know I really really liked that
issue in particular because I'm I don't
want to see a massive pipe of 30 pages
or 24 pages I want to see how is this
dome affected everyone and how does it
affect them after the dome is gone and
is anyone dying well you know you know
what's annoying about the dying factor
if you think what is the most events
that's one of our biggest fears as comic
book fans like are they gonna kill the
guy that I like and then I'm not gonna
see him for 20 years Barry Allen and
it's it's not like I have no fear as to
what's gonna happen in convergence issue
two of every single one of these could
be the world's dying and I'd be like oh
well none of that is the world that I'm
following right now so yeah I and also
we all know that after this DC is just
going for creativity over continuity so
it's like this isn't the last time that
we see a thanks exactly why some people
are skipping the issues altogether and
they're like you said waiting to be like
okay tell me when all this is over I'll
pick up afterwards because that almost
feels like it doesn't matter you know I
I feel as though DC is almost writing
off this event I like because when they
announced the convergence I expected our
new 52 Batman our new 52 Superman it
possibly meeting up the post-crisis and
pre-crisis and preview - and everyone
meeting up it'd be this amazing event
and it's almost as if DC said like
everyone likes to joke about it but I'm
starting to think it's true we're moving
just put out comics that might
sell just to kind of keep things moving
don't even incorporate our main
superheros just use earth to give birth
to a nice send-off with a big event yeah
why I mean I get the people like it and
I'm like if you went with just the
comments I'd be like man earth two is a
huge selling book it's not nor is it
also like a hugely popular series that
said them cramming it down my throat
I've actually been really enjoying those
odd I never really would read him but I
have been enjoying his being Superman
and like his you know Superman eNOS and
his costume Superman eNOS yeah and I dig
like Thomas Wayne for a little while
yeah cuz I'm not gonna buy anymore like
I don't care you don't need to buy
anymore cuz what ended up happening at
the end of the latest issue spoilers I
guess does anyone really care is like
like and that you know what I'm gonna go
in support I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
spoil the latest issue convergence
because no one seems to care Thomas
Wayne gets murdered by the Joker but
it's like that Lee does get murdered
it kills himself he kills himself taking
on everyone except the Joker that's what
it was in the valves like never the
talent shows update but like he goes
down heroically and if you have not been
reading earth-2 if you have not been
reading World's End you don't even know
the heck Thomas witness you homie you
okay the main you're like I guess
Batman's dad survived in one reality and
now he's Batman okay oh man now he's
dead everything's exactly yeah and like
that that's actually one of my favorite
parts from that issue is actually when
the Joker shows up and he's like you
surely you've forgotten forgotten me and
tell us like you're annoying in every
reality yeah that's what I liked it was
like confirmation that the Joker is in
every reality also terrifying
yeah Joker in this reality like do we
have a Joker is the Joker behind Sammy
right now it's Jared so he's a hilarious
man boy so we do more cupboards that
would have been the best segue but I
don't
I don't think a gun was ever you know
I'm really paranoid why did you say that
one convergent title I did really like
this week was Liam Superboy in the
Legion of super-heroes because we saw
Superman cry I didn't finish that book I
gave up on that okay keep reading it
till you see Superman cry it was sad
just because like that because I was
gonna give up but I never at that moment
was like oh okay okay it just touched
something right down in there it made me
feel things did you get the feels we've
asked the feels no I'm not on tumblr
he's not a 12 year old girl on tumblr no
he doesn't get the feel every time I get
a commoner and this is not bashing
anyone who says that but the first time
I did like one of the sad stories on my
channel and I started getting those
comments of you made me hit the feels
Benny and I'm like how old are you I'll
say it sometimes too and I'm not even
sure at this point if I'm saying it
ironically or not so I just I just let
it flow well so so you know what whoa
what let's I want to give you I want to
get the audience's opinion and I think
they have a lot less to lay here so I
think this guy actually can actually get
some actual audience interaction about
convergence but while that's going on I
want to get your guys opinions on the
situating it's somewhere but every week
is a different time period so what that
meant for me was like I'm waiting for
the pre new 52 one to start I don't know
is that suppose to be next week or
tomorrow's issues what was the first
thing was it the first week okay
whatever then I don't care nothing
matters anymore if they were working
backwards yeah so what would the last
one was pre-crisis right yeah that was I
think it was um just post-crisis wasn't
it because we had Supergirl matrix okay
okay no no no the latest one was pre cuz
the Supergirl matrix was the week before
the latest one was the Superman issue in
which Kara got the visions that she's
going to die and then said no I will
still save my brother cousin er ba that
be said that that would add a whole new
dynamic if they're brother and sister
yeah but now so this one was pre-crisis
this week and it for at least for me
I mean I'm not gonna say I'm young but
I'm not that old so I see see for me
like pre-crisis like that that was what
I grew up reading because my how I got
into comics was I got two half-brothers
out 20 years older than me they gave up
on comics and then I inherited all of
their connections so like pre-crisis was
like it I know more about pre-crisis
than I do what in them what's going on
at the moment
and so I'm looking forward to that but
also kind of dreading it and also I feel
like there was a really big missed
opportunity because they could have just
done a Supergirl book that was like
super go on crisis on Infinite Earths
where you just sort of different
Supergirl every two pages or something
and yeah I want something [ __ ] weird
from this event and we don't have
anything weird
we're just kind of dumb it's like this
trying to make everything make sense but
they're like here's our multiverse
here's a thousand different worlds we're
gonna try to make all of it you don't
get Ricky great example they're taking
they're taking like pre-crisis and
they're taking like free new 52 but
they're not literally taking them from
the last issues they're taking the best
moments and then wrapping those in so
because like I make a great example as
the Superboy situation where we're in a
world where there's parallax but we're
treating Superboy like he just came into
being like it like it's not the whole
reign of Superman hasn't even happened
so yeah that's interesting yeah because
parallax happens if I mean my timeline
might be old because older looks after
this is after the return of Superman the
co city that makes that helps Hal go
nuts right so it so at that point
Superboy is around he knows his towers
he's doing everything but with the way
they portray him in the comic book he's
just been made he just got his powers
and then he lost him wait if parallax is
around yeah Young Justice would have
just formed yeah so he wouldn't have
even been anywhere near metropolis at
that time what yeah and he would have
kind of fooled and a lot of powers
instead of being like oh I don't really
know what I'm doing and no one knows who
I am and ya know yeah like in Hawaii or
something never we're not gonna talk
about the Hawaii years I like sir she is
the Hawaii was
oh why you super holy like yeah you
would have been would have been with
young justice all just with Tim Drake
and impulse because there was a good few
months where young justice was just Tim
Drake's through your boiling impulse or
yeah they would have been in Hawaii so
that yeah that timelines way at that
time line I feel like I'm wearing
someone else's underwear now are we are
we actually experiencing a situation
where people are writing stories that
take place in eras that the writers
aren't even really sure about it's like
they're putting creativity on before
continuity I mean they've never warned
us about that why they said they're
going to after the event yeah but they
kind of to kind of imply that this event
was going to be the end of like a
massive continuity like we're gonna
close out and do whatever the Freak we
want
I mean Marvel and DC both said the same
thing haha we don't care anymore raise
you've all tried you figure it out at
least with Marvel decks still keeping
like some form of extended continuity no
they're not they are no they're at least
like at the moment
Sammy you seem to get something to say
where does range of Ultron fit putting
you on the spot where does it fit I
don't know I don't know that's a lot of
that is a lot of nonsense they are
trying to to push at me I'm just I'm
just happy I'm just happy 90s Aquaman
came back and convicted that's all I'm
happy about why nineties Aquaman was
super evil I'm gonna take over the
aquarium and I'm just gonna hang out if
you broke down the whole barrier of oh
I'm writing dolphins and sea horses like
I'm eaten off like Red Hook you can like
replace it with a hook and be the
useless one we'll get some sort of
prosthetic limb let's layer animatronic
or something later out look this is a
world where they fight beings from space
I'm sure they could make a waterproof
prosthetic limb mr. miracle the build
you want or something like that like get
someone who like has access to you know
technology from the new gods or whatever
and yeah but like Aquaman I think later
on when the he'd did he retired when he
cut his hair but he still didn't have a
new hand he replaced the hook hand with
a water hand he did yeah no so but yeah
he didn't need any of that Arsenal
proved we can make an awesome robotic
arm with weapons yeah you could just
cold steel I don't know a Faust you're
the teen tank guy is Arsenal's arm but
waterproof trivia go we've never seen it
in water from what I know but we've also
never seen it blend I don't think it
would blend well really you can turn it
okay so that's gonna be a new show and
foul channel will it blend
Arsenal's arm and he'll just start sort
of random superhero stuff in the blender
will it blend at Superman's cape will it
blend Batman's bat bells will it blend
Wolverine's skeleton oh my god I love
your brooch so anyway so yeah the end of
the day we'll here's my question is
anyone gonna like this like five years
from now is anyone you know [ __ ] you're
gonna read I don't think it's gonna be
remembered yeah right like it's gonna be
like fear itself or just like what I
almost think it's gonna turn into how
access is handed on my channel where
when access is going on all's I got was
non-stop questions of will you explain
access will you do a complete story on
axis and then within a month of axis
ending not a single person wants I mean
we were so on board to do access as a
back issues and then it just and then I
was like hey what does last issue of
access came out and they were like three
weeks ago and I'm like oh like we're
talking about the kind of company that
created crisis on Infinite Earths which
is a lot of people to this day say was
the first event and the best event in
comics they have not been able to top
that since or capture the magic that was
place or something finish ups and until
they do I think all of their events are
just gonna finally lie
that was good but remember crisis on
Infinite Earths I mean the blackest
night came close I think lots of people
like flashpoint I don't know why but
real quick is anybody else getting
static from Faust yes okay so that means
something in your eye Faust I will say
Crescent infinite or your phone and it
really does it was like one of the first
events really but like I like other
events more like I appreciate it but
like as far as reading it goes like I
don't just sit down and read it right
crisis on Infinite Earths like this is a
mess but I will say you know it's funny
like I actually just got gifted a copy
of crisis on Infinite Earths I've read
it in like a decade so I'm like oh boy
gets to sit down and read get to
actually do what I just said I wouldn't
do it I mean like it's who wrote was it
Wolfman I wrote that I think Wolfman
wrote that one yeah it was
Wilfred I wrote it you got George Perez
I was looking over my old episode of
Avengers JLA which is written by you say
I can drawn by Perez and I'm like this
is like ricin and like this is like a DC
crisis in it like DC Marvel presidents
and like I feel like it's a little more
straightforward and I'm kind of like I
prefer that if I'm like talking about
crisis level events I like the Marvel DC
like the jla/avengers crossover that was
like that was the one where someone went
like hey you know we're right in comics
right like let's have fun all the
realities and play with all the
timelines and just do whatever and like
DC will say it happened in Marvel won't
and just move on because they did at the
end of it like they like DC went with it
they were like I remember those guys
over there
then we won't name anyway who cares
moving on a whole movie - they're like
you didn't do that oh well they're like
like in daredevil where they have a
bailiff they have a newspaper of Hulk
smashing New York and in the Avenger is
what Hulk's like I broke Harlem don't
remember it though like don't go and
look it up though because it really
wasn't it really was kind of crappy I
looked completely different yeah I one
of my many transformations as into back
into Bruce Banner kind of messed it all
up
you
morpheus are kind of like that yeah
exactly also my antagonist really sucked
and he looked really yeah like I think
the thing respects at it for me first
let's try to resolve that real fast
everyone dance entertain why do I feel
like we all went to the same kind of we
did fix it yeah that did what was it I
unplugged my mic and plugged it back in
for some reason always works restarting
classic okay so wait real quick before
you can you have your thoughts you need
to dance we dance for you oh now
everyone's watching Faust make it good
I'm just gonna be Ellen so my whole
thing of crisis on Infinite Earths is
that as a whole with them yeah big mess
but like it's got individual stories in
it that are fantastic and then if you
die and they tie into the bigger event
and that's what I feel like is missing
from DC at the moment the individual
stories are readable on their own or you
and they tie into the bigger event
whereas at the moment the individual
story is just a bit like that's
happening I feel like the tions hat
they're like make them separate just put
like the dome in it and that's it like
but write whatever you want I think that
might be actually like a pilot test of
the Kree of the creativity over can't do
anything where they're just like Saudi
who he remembers pre flashpoint okay you
got that book who remembers a post like
pre-crisis okay what do you want to do
in post career in pre crisis you got it
and whatever and just put the dome in it
somewhere
I you know what I feel like it is like
you said I think it's a test but I
almost feel like like like the to to a
more extreme of what you're saying
creativity over continuity when they
literally said we're moving we're not
gonna prove anything you've done just
write it draw it send it in to the
publisher and just get it done like for
two months DC writers have free reign
just pick a continuity and go with it
yeah I haven't what I know for a fact
that that's not entirely true because
Dan Abnett and he actually goes to a
comic book store
- every week and I ever heard a
conversation with him just a few weeks
ago and he was saying because he's
worked on both secret Wars and and on
convergence I forgot its name just then
whatever talking about over 30 minutes
exactly that is the history that is that
is the legacy of convergence and he
basically said that convergence has had
so much editorial rain for like
editorial
yeah like it's insane where a secret was
it's just running like indie comics like
is there a bit like do what you want
have fun
talk to other writers make sure you
don't mess anything up but have fun
that's funny you know what because
nobody no like because everyone just
assumes they're doing whatever they want
and if this is what look what it looks
like when DC is like no it has to be
this way oh and especially from Dan
Abnett like he brought like one of the
best runs in the Legion of super-heroes
like so you know like if he's saying
they're editing my stuff and I'm like
yeah right no it's I love by the way
that what you just said about how like
Marvel is kind of running a like indie
comics like whatever you want to do is
to the Avengers in the Old West and Roy
like you want to do a Man Thing Doctor
Strange Oh like that's awesome like I'm
actually kind of excited for that
because it means that we don't have to
like I don't to worry about like how
it's gonna get tied in especially
because I'm sure that Jonathan Hickman's
ridiculousness probably would be
difficult to anticipate anyway but uh
but that's cool like that's exciting
actually I'm looking forward to Secret
Wars no more which is why I'm looking
forward to X and in 92 even though I the
only one who wants Deadpool's a secret
secret war that's a lot of people that's
why it'll be fun I'm gonna read that cuz
I liked the old secret war book well I'm
gonna get it but I don't usually read
that pull cuz they don't like to talk to
me I was hoping they're bringing you
into the weekly poll I would have
another dead Fox Ari I just I I mean in
little doses like okay you know breaking
the fourth wall Jimmy
junga that's hilarious but like as like
a character well they did like see
that's just that no one knows the whole
last 40 issue run they added a character
and the problem was it didn't sell so
they killed him and they're bringing
back Merc with a mouth haha chimichangas
did you guys see Deadpool's appearance
on ultimate spider-man yes
that was stupid I hated that that was
the quintessence of my problem with
Deadpool and the voice actor they got I
think it was the guy who plays Batman
Beyond no I could have sworn it was
Nolan North
like it wasn't it was like will 3d it
was like Cory Matthews his brother oh
and I was like this is awful like cuz he
just wouldn't shut up and I get that
like that's kind of his character like I
can imagine him interacting another
character with other super heroes or
villains and then being like when is
this guy gonna shut up and that's
hilarious but I don't know having actual
audio attached to it really killed the
character more for me just like da this
guy shut up for the movie so you know
it's an awesome new piece of makeup the
Joker makeup
ah what a thing hold on though I did
want to say real quick we got a couple
of interesting comments first Ivan I
personally could chat for twitch better
because they've been a lot more
responsive overall they've pretty
divided people wanted to twitch they
want YouTube they said if we go back to
YouTube we have to bring Samy and
there's currently a theory running
around that Rob got hit with the
Terrigen mists and turned into Samy
so I'm okay with that I'm not confirming
or denying that theory is much most
interesting inhuman so much like lots of
people a few weeks ago was saying I
actually play Quicksilver in the dudu
age of Ultron movie and this is just
what I look like when I shave actually
this person brought up a very good point
the YouTube live soup does not work in
very many countries this one does but
overall our audience doesn't seem to
care about convergence because no one
there's a few people talking about it
but overall they're just commenting on
the lack of Dave Robb and the inclusion
of Sami so okay let's change topics
Dobby they're all listening I just I
just fine well there's so many theories
about
you Sammy so why don't we take a moment
cuz we've had a lot of new viewers why
don't you just say what your channel is
what you do again yeah just real quick
Sammy is actually she's not a random
person she is a contributor at the
weekly net our community website where
all of the comic book youtubers are
coming together to try and make a
cohesive like community for you guys to
chat with us and chat with each other so
what is your channel about Sammy looks
really good I like it you're so
ambitious up there it's nice to be out
and stuff but yeah I'm Sammy and I
recently made a chance called Sam green
fist hold on a second Sam you're
actually breaking up so it's probably
the worst time to plug your channel
that's like my channel is YouTube dot
you're my minute up we'll come back to
your plug in a second let's just see if
it kind of cleans up here cuz the
problem that one of the issues were
having a twitch guys is I don't normally
host a call I'm in the mountains which
means that I have good internet and then
bad internet and then good internet
again
sound normally host yeah
so why don't we and it's probably gonna
completely mess up everything and I'm no
cool okay all right give Sammy one more
shot a except again and we'll try it
Sammy you're frozen don't forget to
commit no litter literally my name is
Sammy and I started a YouTube channel
where I talk about comics and it's much
more discussion based while you guys
have channels that are I guess with the
exception of comic pop are very much
more informative on the comics you know
world I'm kind of aiming and you know
I'm kind of because I sort of somewhat
just started I'm kind of figuring out
what exactly the aim is but but it's I
mean I've been doing weekly like talking
about what's been in my comics poll and
then I've also just been talking about
basically whatever's going on in the
comics community and it's been really
fun I love interacting with people it's
awesome
doing a lot of amazing stuff over there
I find remember correctly and I may be
wrong about this but at least Sal found
her first foundered came across her
channel okay you were me I think it was
you actually oh no you know what I found
you because you did the comics uno
unboxing and they were promoting your
video oh yeah I do remember it was the
comic bento thing yeah bento that was it
yeah not coming you know was the channel
she's gonna be on eventually to sell us
to work that out guys but uh oh ya know
cow he's been to desert that's why I
found and Sal and I were talking about
trying to bring in people but anyway
let's go ahead and discuss another
amazing segue so does anybody have any
interesting tattoos on their body like
the Joker the only one of us I could see
having hahaha tattooed at their body
would be fast I can't get tattoos ever
why I'm a model and if I have tattoos
that look like cuts half of my jobs well
there you go do it
I know why I think it might have just
been the cadence from with which you
said I'm a model but it really almost
sounded like you were gonna break into
Right Said Fred I was really excited for
a minute so we're gonna be like I'm a
model and you know what I mean and I do
my little turn on the catwalk but anyway
let's know know what fashion it was like
anyway uh know what's going on is uh
basically if you guys missed it and I
don't know how you did but they released
a supposed promotional image of what the
Joker's going to look like in the
Suicide Squad movie and then almost
immediately redacted that stating that
it was just a promotional image for the
75th anniversary of the Joker um it's
it's a scrawny Joker with tattoos all
over his body
no grin just may lipstick he's got a
grill on which I thought was the
weirdest thing because I couldn't decide
if it was a grill or rotting teeth the
way they did it there was like hurt
their like teeth caps because on our
Facebook page like it erupted into a
into a debate about how awesome that
look was and I'm like what's happening
to the world like like did the dome just
drop like the hall
oh you were there like it for me it
wasn't even like they didn't even look
like rotting teeth it looked like
someone had just stuck grapes yeah and
like the the the explanation from the
fan base at least has been that like Oh
Batman's stronger than Joker and of
course he would have knocked out his
teeth those are teeth caps because
Joker's teeth have been destroyed by
Batman over the years I mean like duh
and I'm like oh right because the the 75
years of not having that have been so
confusing for you and now it's finally
made sense like no you're just trying to
justify this horrible look way by like
just grasping it strong oh no he has
teeth cast because Batman's strong any
punches he de no like it looks dumb I
should be I can believe that though I
could totally believe that yeah I know
but like stop like stop legitimizing
things and suck like like just agree
that it's crappy [ __ ] why don't you guys
say that and like the whole thing with
the tattoos is can you actually see the
Joker going into a tattoo parlor and I'm
girl what is not nothing against of why
did the Joker just become gay like I
mean because he never did anything with
Harley to begin with but look I'm not
saying that you think about man but the
Joker's got a thing for Batman can into
hey bats we should totally do this whole
Prince of Gotham kind of thing and by
the way what do you know I always looked
at the Joker's being asexual or like
leaning towards like if if Joker was
ever like to to be in love with anyone
it would be Batman but I don't think
it's a sexual thing I think it's like a
like an infatuation kind of thing see I
always yeah I would say it's like an
infatuation and the reason he can't get
Batman and the reason why he always goes
back is like he's like a woman scorned
but like
like what's going well his new origin
which I'm hoping in the fort and issue
40 we finally fight which comes out
tomorrow I believe or oh well I hope we
finally find out if it's actually the
new Canon for Joker or if it's not but
in the new orange and he's been around
forever and that's exactly it easy fact
you into the Batman because he just
can't defeat Batman and he needs the
chaos and Batman keeps giving order and
it's just like a whole thing I would bet
money they don't resolve it
that whole phages leave it open and then
just move past convergence cuz yeah I
mean I'm knocking this ball forward
because there's a huge spoiler in there
that's been talked about everywhere but
yeah reading oh sorry no I just read the
comment that was Brokeback Gotham I mean
like if you've read any trades for free
comic book day then it's already ruined
but like yeah I don't know no we
shouldn't ruin that on the on the
podcast no I don't want to because I'm
gonna make a video about it I don't want
you to ruin my video when I did a title
and yeah I wouldn't be surprised if like
they leave it open-ended with the Joker
like where it's like you know is he
immortal or not I don't you know who
knows I got a feeling just ya know ring
with you I think they're gonna heavily
imply that it is accurate but we're
never gonna get a confirmation so that
if they want to come back to here later
and be like nope all of that is baloney
you know it's fine
you know why I feel that way cuz I had
because I've read that already in a book
called court of owls where it's heavily
implied but maybe not so you can have
both so nobody can can criticize me oh
the brother thing yeah yeah well it may
and they pseudo resolved that finding an
eternal they're like no I everybody know
you're not fight fight fight
I would yeah oh by the way that's the
complete story for Batman eternal that's
it right there
I won't spoil the next the last issue in
like a six-issue run but I will spoil
the last issue in a sixty issue hi ho
see I did a weekly sort of recap of
Batman internal and I had a green screen
and everything in comment comic was
going in the background I basically tell
people what happened in every issue and
I got to like issue 17 you know when
nothing's happening in this I just can I
just have a Stephanie Brown series
because that's literally the only bit
I'm
didn't I second that the um the problem
of that mini turtle and this is and
actually I'll tell a funny little
antidote um the first time that we had
Aris come on the channel he wanted to
talk about Batman eternal and I'm the
big DC guy sounds the middle-of-the-road
guy Rob's obviously the Marvel guy at
this time this that was the three of us
doing this so like we found her heirs
was gonna be on there and I had three
days because I gave up a better term
like issue five and at the time we were
like an issue 23 and I read all the way
from 1 to 23 in a single day just
blitzing through every issue of Batman
eternal and I got to the end and 23 does
the flip word gets interesting
and it was the 40 I've heard that yeah
23 is where you find out it's where hush
is introduced and the whole thing goes
in a different direction um but I have
found the funniest thing was just like
you a lot of people gave up on 17
because that's where it was like why are
we cycling characters like this but like
with a weekly title you can't do that
you can't make your exciting things
happen way later I mean you're gonna
lose readerships what they did but even
Eris got on and he had only read up to
17 and sods rating and so I had read Oh
remember that dare I sell I have read
past eras and I know you're like damn it
well I want to spoil for you like that's
what they did that was another issue
like 52 like they kept cycling
characters and it just didn't exactly
work and I think like that just comes
with weekly series in general if you've
got a lot of stories going on at once
you're gonna be cycling characters and
all the good stuff is gonna happen later
on and no one wants to wait that long no
so let's go around let's go around the
room you know I just realized we could
technically put all of our cameras
together and make one room but anyway
let's go around the room and decide just
because we're a little off topic now
let's just look what you guys individual
opinions on the Joker's makeup situation
is listen Sammy let's have you go first
unless you don't want to all right no
I'll take it
I'll go I'll take it um I I feel like I
see what they're trying to go for
they're trying to go for a more
realistic I think right like oh this is
what Joker would look like today I think
but I I'm trying like with everything I
am I'm trying so hard to reserve
mint of Jared letter Leto's Joker until
I see the movie yeah I'm trying but I
know he's very Macaulay Culkin and it
just was an odd
I just I'm now picturing I'm now
picturing Jared little Joker just being
like well now I'm imagining like the
home alone like yeah but like with like
Batman pressed against the window behind
oh no I'm coming no you got to do it as
Ben Affleck's Batman oh yeah I'm real
quick and we're gonna get a fast opinion
on the Derek joka thing I will say this
everyone's completely bashing the oh no
of Batman's auto-tune that makes more
sense than Batman talking like just
because he's wearing the the the the
armor I think the one way that means
gonna sound like Ben Affleck doesn't
that make sense though like that he
would that would be a robotic masking to
his voice instead of like tearing apart
his own vocal cords yeah I think it
matters who cares like whatever like I
think it's only auto-tuned because he's
wearing that the The Dark Knight armor I
think when he's regular Batman was
wearing like the actual suit I think
he's just gonna be like a more gruff Ben
Affleck that's what I think I don't know
if it's like if if like Scott Snyder
wrote in like the you know margins of
Batman 40 like by the way they use robot
like he uses a robot like auto tuner to
make him I would be like no that's dumb
like oh you know I'm just picturing like
an editor's note between two panels I
read it like this yeah Sam you were
trying to say something about the voice
thing that was being so rude and
interrupting you don't remember it all
do all right fast what's your opinion on
Joker I think there's this song by the
drag queen called Alaska and it's called
your makeup is terrible and that that's
how I feel
I just I can't see the Joker going and
getting tattoos I don't imagine the
Joker sitting still for that long
if the tattoos looked like he did them
on himself as something of masochistic
thing be done with that it doesn't look
like that it looks like he's literally
gone into a parlor when I want some ha
host on that and like and he's ripped so
he just he's such a douche like he just
looks like a douche where he's like he's
always like oh I'm gonna work on my
delts today and then after that I'm
gonna get a big smiling lip on my on my
other arm maybe they're temporary
tattoos yeah that could be I mean it
just goes home every night is like oh my
god I hate this all the variations of
the bat symbol I might be a little bit
more okay with it but the thing that
Joker with tattoos is dumb anyway like
when the Frank Miller when will Gimli
unveil that one image from all-star
Batman Robin we had the dragon tattoo on
his back his whole back I was like this
is really stupid but you know I don't
know this is me
it's whatevs well I why they say what's
your opinion on the 10th out the costume
and make them sell but I think you've
kind of unless you have more to say in
the top I mean as far as like okay so
let's go down the checklist he's got
green hair right on his skin is bleached
okay and he's got red lips yeah I guess
you're good
I've actually never really seen Jared
Leto act so I'm reserving judgment on it
I mean the fact is like Daniel day-lewis
could be the Joker he might not do a
good job I'd reserve judgment on anybody
at that point but like you know as far
as that image looks it looks really dumb
and I don't care who knows it
I don't care who I piss off in this room
full of people I emailed but you know
the the Joker makeup looks dumb now that
said I think that the idea is that like
as we said it's a promotional image or
it's it's like one
look for the Joker I wouldn't even mind
if it was a Joker that was unveiled as
like part of like the new 50 like not
even the new 52 but like in the
multiverse there's a joker who like
really cares about like ink and like
idea like was really into you know
I mean I got tattoos and I know guys
we've got a lot of tattoos and a lot of
them get new discussions about the
judges could you just picture the Joker
hanging out with his gang what a nice
again so uh I got hahaha cuz I like to
tell jokes and I just want to tell
people to laugh and I got damaged
because you know cuz damage is just
that's how I feel inside that's yeah I'm
in beats I mean that's that's that's and
then and then I just didn't brush my
teeth for three years and I got being a
bad guy doesn't really help with that I
also have this great bat [ __ ] stamp
right honey Dan Slott tweeted that one
out does the Joker have a bat [ __ ]
stamp nice I was right I mean like if
you're doing that you might as well like
at least then it would be funny I'd be
like all right I get it the chat like
five minutes ago said what if Holly gave
joke and the tattoos still a terrible
idea because Holly
Tom touched the Joker like they get that
physically close to him like yes she
wants to get that physically poster I'm
sure they Kali would die if she could
like give the Joker tattoos but like she
just can't and she's in dislikes of
relationship non relationship kind of
thing with him that it's weird and
twisted and I love it ya know I just did
the research for the script for our
Harley coin origins it'll come out
eventually guys we're just doing a whole
bunch of scripts in advance but it's
done um and that's part of her whole
thing where she's like I got it close to
the Joker I became what he wanted me to
be I became his ditz like they're
playing off that she is actually as
smarter and she was pretending because
that's what the Joker wanted but they
stayed like she never really got that
close to him and eventually he just was
done with her and moved on there was
actually one point where Holly captured
Batman and was ready to kill him and the
joker walked in was like Oh what have
you done here Holly and I was like I did
your job for you
she says she calls him stuff like that
fouls from now on you need to refer to
me as schnookums
I will do it so much you'll be very
uncomfortable second thought let's not
go that around we're going weird cool
again
forget it that was amazing that was med
love and that was that was a I love that
moment that was like yeah that was the
whole culmination in their relationship
where he's just like at that moment he
just couldn't detest her more I loved
that moment where he's like oh like what
if I be he's like what do I even doing
at that point like the her dressed like
Harley I think for him he was like this
is vulgar whatever we're doing here like
you you took Batman I took one of my
ideas and then you explained to me how
it works
you have to die yeah yeah I like that
relation I like that relationship in
that but it shows like if Holly
genuinely was as insane as the Joker
she'd stab him
yeah she should be back soon yeah I'm
but she's just not quite that insane
she's not insane I'm a faun I'm a funny
side note I don't know if any of you
guys read it but did you read the Harley
Quinn Valentine's issue where she dated
Batman and then they had a they went on
a date together she won him in an
auction they actually went on a real
date then they both got hit with a gas
that had dreams of what life would be
like if they got married was that one
was that the scratch-and-sniff like pods
nothing one I'm sorry I'm getting mine
that was hilarious like she imagined
herself married to Bruce Wayne and his
massive fortune and the two of them
becoming superheroes by knighted who
needs Robin who needs Alfred I have it I
just haven't read it yet because I liked
half of the Christmas special I didn't
like the Thanksgiving special so I'm
like I want to like Harley Quinn so
badly I really do but I just yeah but
the problem I have at Harlequins book
just will digress for a second here is
I'd like the Harley Quinn book when they
tell a story the problem is they seem to
want to enter splice non stories like oh
now she's going to go collect rent from
a tenant and try to go on a date now
she's going to go into an interspace
dimensional pics exploration party
with power girl and now she's gonna go
to her roller derby good well that's
what my issue is but the opposite
they're trying to put in a story to a
book that should just be about
misadventures it should literally just
be the misadventures of Harley Quinn and
I think it would work a lot better like
that because why the hell does Harley
Quinn need a plot she's Harley Quinn
we're not gonna see development there
well it's like this what I think I think
what I think they should do is have both
and I think they're doing that where we
have Harley Quinn and Power Girl so I
think that's gonna be like the arcing
Harley Quinn on adventures and then
we'll have the misadventures of Harley
Quinn having a crazy time what are we
doing the man's somebody give me symbols
it'll look like you had something to say
about Harley Quinn Sammy I'm trying to
go off your facial reads but I always
yeah I just yeah I mean I think it just
depends on the writer I mean hardly can
be like you said either she can have a
story or she cannot but it depends on
how they're dealing with her insane
personality I mean she can be either
done as like a sex symbol or she can be
done as a crazy fun you know what I mean
like yeah I think that's the best way to
put it it's all about the writer they
need to decide what and that's what I
feel with the book I feel like they
don't know what they want to do so by
throwing ideas at a wall hoping
something sells like hotcakes and that's
what's gonna make the book like I keep
getting the book because it's one of my
favorite comics every month
stylistically I like your fashions in it
it's it's very modern of the UH in it I
like a lot and so if the story lies we
just talked about that yeah we just lost
sales video I'll be back hey so yeah we
already lost you too it's it's good I
I'm having some legs that we are testing
the twitch thing deprived to tweak it a
few things guys um we are losing quality
here and there as you probably have seen
some of the cameras are dipping out but
this is stuff we will perfect in the
future just as our first run on it which
so we gotta kind of get to figure what
we're doing um but anyway what I was
gonna say next is I think we've talked
enough about the Joker makeup way it's
the whole conversation digress to do a
series of different tangents and okay
I don't know how we started talking my
Harley Quinn I guess we talk about Joker
you can't know this didn't get that far
yeah but I think it's time for the ED
super effective I've tried to yell I
don't think I did it very well but my
conduit
what is your opinions on the way and Sam
but you had a great opinions on this so
why don't you two explain to us the
opinions on how they handled Bobby
drinks coming-out party
no I want pals to go first um no I don't
wanna express opinion before before I
hear what he has to say okay so I
thought real quick before it cuz let me
explain the situation so people know
what you're about to rant about so
recently in the all-new x-men which is a
story about time-displaced x-men from
the past they've been put into the
current timeline so we have our current
x-men and we have the original x-men so
what they've recently done in the
all-new x-men is Jean Grey basically
read Bobby drake's mind and discovered
he's gay and the one they had was about
four pages of her insisting he's gay and
her telling or not and then I'm trying
to figure out how he's gay but future
Bobby Drake isn't gay and what they're
gonna do and what they should do it was
a whole thing where they basically
instead of having like any proper way or
whatever and I'm sure fast to talk about
all this stuff in a minute they
literally just said hey Bobby you're gay
he's like what no like you're gay and
that's the whole thing they just kept
going so that's what we're about to talk
about it made headlines on the comic
rounds faust what is your opinion on
this okay so for everyone that's it I
don't know even know where to start with
this so okay this is a bit of a beast
first off I don't think it's a bad thing
that's Bobby's that Bobby's gay for
everyone that's saying you can't just
turn an iconic character gay he's
supposed to be straight you've got a lot
more straight characters to choose from
we're not stealing all of them were
stealing one one that lots of people
don't even care about so at the end of
the day you've got a lot more straight
characters to choose from secondly
anything can happen in comics if you're
okay with a girl that can turn sound
into light going to space getting the
power cosmic and diving into a black
hole you're okay with a character
finding out he's bit or with finding out
that a character that's been around
since the 60s has been closeted to this
whole
time and yes he's dated girls but that's
how being in the closet works
surprisingly you date girls tribe try
and make people think you're straight
that being said the way it was done I
think it would have been a lot more
powerful and a lot more relevant to the
LGBT community if we had the actual
Bobby Jake a just just coming out just
being develop his relationship with
Kitty Pryde and then sort of say I can't
do this I can't do this anymore
I'm gay that would have been a lot more
powerful a lot more relevant to how the
LGBT community is perceived in this
world and actually be a lot more
relevant to what people go through
because by just having gene Greg oh hey
been reading your mind recently like it
that was just a bit like it was an
anti-climax and a bit insulting I guess
it's just like coming out is a big big
deal and it just made it seem like hey
you can come out and be accepted by
having your friend read your actions
yeah I think that was the part that I
disliked the most was that it was more
like he kept saying like stop don't read
my mind he said that so many times and
she still invaded his privacy like that
mostly was the part that upset me I
don't know why she kept doing that but
that kind of was bothering me yeah and
especially think like okay it kind of
shows the immaturity of this gene
because like I know lots of closeted
people I act like from sort of reading
their actions and sort of saying okay
yeah when I was in the closet that was
me but I don't out them because that's a
[ __ ] thing to do and I'm sure they
just sort of shows their maturity of
this version of gene that I wouldn't
want to say I love gene now but doing
that I'm sort of like gene right
overall I haven't liked this version of
gene at all cuz ever since she showed up
she's been like oh I'm gonna turn it to
a god-like super-powered being now I
have psionics
it's like what like she the Jean Grey
character at least she's interesting now
but at the same time like I don't know
if Bendis meant for Jean to look like a
dick and that's where I have the problem
like my issue is really like is it do it
betrays the lack of understanding of
that situation for me and I'm like you
know maybe have him do it or maybe have
him get upset with her for having taken
it from him like I feel like that was
really like not cool and I'm like and I
would like to see that maybe if Venice
is a genius and he does actually decide
to like carry that over like if Bobby is
like really upset he's just like I'm I
there's too much to deal with I'm not
gonna like I'm gonna scream at you right
now that is better but if I'm hoping
that the story isn't just like Bobby
wasn't willing to do it we know this
because it's 2015 and he's still
straight so we have Jean do it and now
it's done now the damage that we're done
like move on and I hope that's not the
case I hope it's more like complicated
and interesting and and dramatic I don't
know I just feel like what Jean did was
not okay and I hope that they know that
when they were writing it and like not
to be deep but to be deep I think like
the way the media like sharp about
because it wasn't just comic book
websites
it was mainstream media talking about
this I think it shows just how little we
progressed since Ellen's coming out in
the 90s it was the same situation it was
everywhere it was suddenly iconic
character likes the D and it was
ridiculous it like every news out there
and and every media outlet is now saying
it's okay to be gay it doesn't matter
but as soon as someone comes out they're
like they're gay oh my god is it the end
of the world or do I want what do you
guys think what
what if you think that this was like
almost like a testbed platform where
they were like say if he's gay see what
the response is and if it doesn't work
out suka Wars will revert the whole
thing every time I ever happen that
would piss off the LGBT community yeah I
mean I such a good like opportunity to
do something with it and they didn't
they use it very poorly if that was what
they were doing that was not a good way
I mean that I feel like by saying like
oh let's see if this is okay see how the
audience responds to it I mean that's
kind of a bad setting a bad precedent
for how it is in real life like do you
come out as gay and then see how people
feel about it and then oh no I
I read act it because you know what I
mean like so that would be never I mean
I've seen a lot of TV shows about I
don't know that many gay individuals
myself but I've never heard of anyone go
I'm like I'm super gay
not really you guys didn't accept never
seen it actually happen fast or is it
like once they're out they're out
I mean I think like people say like Oh
once you're out you're out like in
reality I have to come out at least once
a week because I mean I mix it like this
is the thing that comics just don't get
when you come out that's not the only
time you come out every time you meet
someone new you have to be like are they
a homophobic person I'm just gonna kind
of dance around this for a couple of
weeks and just suddenly casually work in
that I like dudes and see how they react
oh they reacted badly okay bye forever I
worked for the record you didn't
casually dancer on anything with us I
don't know if you knew if you assumed it
we knew all men watch my videos no no
there's no episode where in which you
say like hey everybody I'm gay but like
yeah exactly like i watched any of my
first 10 videos where i'm out of my mind
drunk we don't go that far back but we
were looking at bringing you on we
watched a good chunk of over and i think
the action question was he may or may
not be let's not approach it and then
just you got in one call and you're like
so as a gay man i'm like he's gay that
far back but which mojo does that's an
argument all unto itself
watch Rodos like we're gonna go as far
back as humanly possible to things he
hasn't done in months
everyone's like it's fast gay is fast
games like do I speak another language
with gay like ten times yeah
know it for the record we we are it just
to reaffirm what you're talking about
right now I would say we've gotten at
least a third of the comments right now
since we started talking about this of
is Foust gay
like I'm not even joking
so the question really will become
moving on is the question of like what
does this mean for current Bobby and I
think the idea here is and I think
Marvel has actually said out loud like
no he is - like we'll deal with that
like we're getting there
do you believe them see I think see
models much better with gay characters
than they are with then we'll compare to
DC oh yeah cuz DC is like you can have
one gay character at any given time and
they will have their own book and when
your book is cancelled
they will disappear for 10 years yes
well unless you can't well wait no you
had that woman we're talking that woman
and and the question for the one not
only do they have to share the same book
but they have to date and they also
can't get married I still I'm still I'm
not even gay but I'm still irritated how
they handled the whole Green Lanterns
gay situation he gives one page on the
one thing that you totally felt like
this was probably a woman in the
original version and then they just bare
we're gonna feel a lot of totally
mind-bending if then we made him gay and
it wasn't even like I like it wasn't
even a lantern that mattered not to say
like there were certain Mills but you
know if they turned around and just
suddenly said how Jordans gay
then people would have been all up in
arms about it and it would have been
fantastic but since it was just an actor
that didn't matter
yeah it's they didn't even take the
original Alan Scott they're like here's
a new ver
you've never heard of who just shares
his name yeah I'll by the way he's gay
he is to blame so yeah at least at least
gay people we have our own version of
Superman and Lois Lane in Billy and
Teddy like you can't break Billy and
Teddy up otherwise I will come down or
star in the other guy right or I got it
wrong no no Billy and Teddy are the two
characters from The Young Avengers
that's really that's a really great I
really dig like good for them like good
like they yeah don't break them up and
also like I like that it's just a
relationship then it's not like oh this
is our gay relationship and we point to
whenever we want to talk about how
progressive we are it's just like just a
nice little it's just a thing like it's
a it's a consequence of these characters
all like cohabitating and that's cool
like I like and they joke about it like
when Billy had to change his code name
to Wiccan from Asgardian because they
knew if the media found out about him
and Teddy they would joke about the
whole Asgardian sounding like ass
guardian so I did a whole team America
thing from like forever ago that vestige
of how old there's usually no the
reference I there's an old movie from
when I was a kid called Team America in
which they were a puppets running around
and there was Matt Damon and it was made
with the South Park guys and Matt
Damon's role was entirely Matt Damon as
all he said the entire movie wait you've
never seen gosh you're also getting old
I'm just letting you know now I will
never get old by the time I'm 50 I will
have so much plastic surgery my body
parts will only just the 18 years of age
you're very passionate about that though
Jerry
because it's true have you ever met Joan
Rivers no I won't die from I'm sorry
Wow alright and on that note I think we
should do it official and guys we're
gonna hang out a little bit afterwards
because I do want to chat see what you
guys preferred what you guys didn't
prefer that kind of a situation but we
are going to officially close the
recording of this and if Rob does free
upload this on to his channel that's
what he'll be doing so let in closing of
our actual podcast podcast portion of
this I'm Benny the comic store Ian you
guys know who I am I think most of you
guys came from my channel on Rob's and
we do a lot of collabs anyway so oh but
it's bat is youtube.com backslash comics
Taurean saliz from comic pop they do a
lot of weekly stuff or they chitchat and
they have like discussions about comic
books with him being the veteran and two
guys who don't know what's going on at
comic books and they talk about it and
they do a lot of other shows around
there that honestly I'm not I'm not
trying to be rude but I just ran out of
time and can't watch them all but but if
you're looking for great discussions
that's Rob Foust does a lot of history
of discusses a lot of stuff I'm sure you
guys know who its super effective is at
this point I can't do it but he does a
lot of great stuff just at a spider grin
video and our guest today is Sammy reads
if you do a youtube search for Sammy
reviews you will find her and I will
post a link right now and that is it
again it clicks it but she's a
contributor for world deaded world wide
web she is a contributor for WWE weekly
pulled net a website where the entire
comic book YouTube community is
attempting to come together to give you
a community where you can chat read
articles see all of her videos and she
is a part of that contributing videos
you can find her on the bottom right now
because contributors are on the bottom
and but due to a glitch she is the only
contributor even though she's not if she
is proud of that do you want to say
anything
Sami about your channel real quick
before we kind of sign off on the
officials yeah um I'm just I'm here to
hang out and chat this is the word self
promo you'll get used to it trust me
eventually you get used to self
promoting it's fine but no yeah Sammy's
got a great channel she does a lot of
discussion she does similar to TV little
s'en fout the Duff vows to cut stuff
this Sal does but with her own brand
different from it so it is different
it's not just a carbon copy or anything
like that
um I think that's all we have Rob is
expected back next week guys we don't
know where this is going to be located
and maybe on his channel we may come
back here we may talk to twitch like
we're trying and get a weekly pull
channel if we don't we may be here
everyone I will not be here yeah tweet
at twitch to say the weekly pulled deeds
it's channel yeah I actually might go
badly and they might ignore us don't do
that thank you guys for joining us today
like I said we are gonna hang around a
little bit afterwards but we are doing
an official close to the podcast portion
of our podcast and I don't know what
else to say bye okay and that that'll be
where the video cuts off I'm gonna
actually hit end on it right here it's
probably it's still record